اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الكرام الى حصاد هذه
الليله معكم السي ابي عاصي في الوقت الذي
احدثكم فيه تقع احداث وتتفاعل اخرى
البدايه من ليبرفيل عاصمه الجابون التي
شهدت انقلابا عسكريا اليوم توج بهذا
المشهد لاعلان المجلس العسكري اختيار قائد
الحرس الجمهوري الجنرال بريس اولي نيجيما
قائدا للمرحله
الانتقاليه وهذه الصور تريدنا من باريس
حيث قال المتحدث باسم الحكومه الفرنسيه
تعليقا على انقلاب الجابون نندد بالانقلاب
العسكري ونجدد التزامنا بانتخابات حره
وشفافه ماذا عن الموقف الامريكي هذه الصور
من البيت الابيض حيث قال منس الاتصالات
الاستراتيجيه في مجلس الامن القومي ان
الوضع مقلق جدا وانهم سيواصلون بذل كل ما
في وسعهم لدعم المثل الديمقراطيه التي
يعبر عنها الشعب
الافريقي الى نيويورك ومن مبنى الامم
المتحده دان الامين العام للمنظمه الدوليه
بشده محاوله الانقلاب الجاريه في الجابون
داعيا جميع الاطراف الى ضبط النفس
والحوار
وفي مواضيع الحصاد لهذه
الليله انقلاب في الجابون قاده الانقلاب
يعلنون احاله الرئيس علي بونجو الى
التقاعد وقائد الحرس الجمهوري يؤدي القسم
رئيسا للمرحله الانتقاليه والرئيس المحتجز
يدعو المجتمع الدولي
للمساعده في ردود الفعل الاتحاد الافريقي
دين ويدعو لاستعاده النظام الدستوري فرنسا
تش د دد على ان حل ازمه الجابون هو
الانتخابات وليس الانقلاب بيجين تدعو
لعوده النظام الطبيعي وواشنطن تدعو لضبط
النفس
والحوار وعشيه اجتماع لوزراء الخارجيه
الاتحاد الاوروبي يمهد الطريق لعقوبات على
قاده انقلاب النيجر ويؤكد عدم تلقي طلب من
المجموعه الافريقيه لتمويل اي عمل عسكري
محتمل هجمات روسيه اوكرانيه متبادله هي
الاعنف منذ اشهر موسكو تعلن تضرر اربع
طائرات في مطار بسكوف وتتهم الغرب بتوفير
معلومات استخباريه لكييف لمهاجمه العمق
الروسي واوكرانيا تعلن تعرض كيف لاعنف
هجوم جوي
روسي
[موسيقى]
في لقائنا اليومي قبل الحصاد على منصاتنا
الرقميه ناقشنا سياق واسباب الانقلابات
العسكريه المتتاليه في القاره الافريقيه
احدث انقلاب هو في الجابون بطبيعه الحال
لاستطلاع ارائكم بشان هذا الموضوع كنا
طرحنا عليكم السؤال التالي في رايكم ما هي
ابرز اسباب الانقلابات العسكريه في
افريقيا جاءت ردودكم كالتالي
52% قالوا ان تدهور الاوضاع المعيشيه هو
سبب الانقلابات بينما راى
26% ان السياق والاسباب تتعلق بالصراع على
السلطه واعتبر
22% ان غياب الديمقراطيه واحتكار السلطه
هو ما وراء
الانقلابات هذا السؤال سيبقى مطروحا على
منصاتنا الرقميه ويمكنكم دخول صفحه
التصويت عبر مسح رمز كيو ار الظاهر على
الشاشه لقاؤنا على المنصات الرقميه يتجدد
يوميا ونتطرق خلاله لقضايا مستجده ومتفاعل
عربيا
[موسيقى]
ودوليا
اذا عين قاده الانقلاب العسكري في الجابون
اليوم قائد الحرس الجمهوري الجنرال بريس
اوليجي نجيما رئيسا للمرحله الانتقاليه
بعد ما اعلنوا فجرا استيلائهم على سلطه
ورفضهم نتائج الانتخابات الرئاسيه التي
فاز فيها بولايه ثالثه علي بونجو الذي
تمسك اسرته بمفاصل السلطه منذ 55
عاما بلد افريقي اخر يستيقظ على سيطره
العسكر على السلطه فبعد مده قصيره من
اعلان لجنه الانتخابات في الجابون فوز
الرئيس علي بونجو بفتره ثالثه اعلنت
مجموعه من ضباط الجيش والحرس الجمهوري
استيلائها على السلطه والغاء الانتخابات
وحل مؤسسات الدوله والمحكمه الدستوريه
واغلاق حدود البلاد حتى اشعار اخر قبل ان
يخرجوا لاحقا على التلفزيون الرسمي
ويعلنوا وضع الرئيس بونجو قيد الاقامه
الجبريه واعتقال احد ابنائه ورئيس
البرلمان واعضاء في الحكومه بتهمه الفساد
والخيانه العظمى كما اختار قاده الانقلاب
قائد الحرس الجمهوري بر
قائدا للمرحله
الانتقاليه الرئيس المنقلب عليه ظهر بدوره
في تسجيل مصور من مكان احتجازه ووجه رساله
الى كل العالم والاصدقاء للتحرك ضد
معتقليه مضيفا بانه لا يدري ما يحدث وان
ابنه محتجز في مكان ما وان زوجته مفقوده
ومع عوده خدمه الانترنت التي كانت الحكومه
قطعتها منذ السبت الماضي قبيل اغلاق مراكز
الاقتراع نشرت عبر منصات التواصل
الاجتماعي في الجابون مشاهد لمظاهرات
متفرقه في العاصمه ليبرفيل مؤيده للانقلاب
العسكري وفي ردود الفعل الاولى على
الانقلاب اعلن رئيس مفوضيه الاتحاد
الافريقي موسى فكي انه يدين بشده الانقلاب
في الجابون ويعتبره انتهاكا صارخا لقواعد
الاتحاد الافريقي ودعا في بيان الى ضمان
سلامه الرئيس علي بونجو وعائلته بدوره
اعلن مجلس السلم والامن التابع للاتحاد
الافريقي عقد اجتماع طارئ مع بوروندي
والسنغال والكاميرون لبحث التطورات في
الجابون وفي باريس اعلن المتحدث باسم
الحكومه عن ادانه فرنسا للانقلاب في
الجابون وشدد على ضروره احترام نتائج
الانتخابات في حين اعرب مصدر في الاليزيه
عن امله عوده للنظام الدستوري هناك البيت
الابيض قال انه يراقب الوضع في الجابون عن
كثب وانما يحدث امر يبعث على القلق وان
واشنطن ستواصل التركيز على العمل مع
شركائها الافارقه وشعوب القاره للمساعده
في دعم
الديمقراطيه المتحدثه باسم الخارجيه
الروسيه قالت ان بلادها تتابع ايضا بقلق
التقارير عن الاوضاع في الجابون وانها
تامل عوده الاستقرار هناك في اقرب وقت اما
الخارجيه الصينيه فدعت الاطراف المعنيه
هناك الى العوده للنظام الطبيعي فورا
وضمان سلامه الرئيس علي
بونجو من ليبرفيل ينضم الينا جان كلود نمو
الكاتب الصحفي مرحبا بك سيد جان كلود كيف
تبدو الاوضاع اليوم او في هذه الاثناء في
ليبروفيل لاسيما على الصعيد
الامني
بالفعل وبعد نهار ساده
الهدوء ان طرقات ليبرفيل
وعدد كبير من
المدن بقيت فارغه في فتره ما بعد الظهر
بعد خروج الناس في مظاهرات واجابه عن
سؤالكم اذا كان هناك عمل على توافق اراء
على مستوى اللجنه الانتقاليه واللجنه كما
تعرفون اعلنت ان الجنرال اوليج انجيما سوف
يكون الشخصيه التي سوف تقود المرحله
الانتقاليه لفتره لم تحدد بعد وبالتالي في
ليبرفيل ما من شيء جديد هناك استقرار ونحن
في انتظار يوم الغد لكي نعرف ما سوف يحصل
وسوف يعود الناس الى اعمالهم كالمعتاد طيب
هل كانت اي هل كانت هناك اي ردود فعل سجلت
من القوى السياسيه المحليه من قوى
المعارضه التي كانت تنافس الرئيس بونجو
حيال هذه الخطوه التي قام بها
العسكريون
حتى اللحظه الراهنه رد
الفعل
كان قد عبر عنه المرشح بير كافير وهو كان
المرشح
للانتخابات الرئاسيه
وقد حي الخطوه التي قام بها
العسكريون التي ادت الى وضع حد لهذا الحكم
في البلاد
و المرشح الاساسي في وجه علي بونجو لم
يدلي بتصريح رسميا بعد اذا الحزب المعارض
ذكر هذا الموضوع ولكن المرشح لم يضلي
بتصريح رسمي اذا هذا هو الوضع في ليبرفيل
ما المعلومات عن الرئيس بونجو لا سما انه
ظهر وقال انه معتقل في منزله وايضا
المعلومات عن باقي المسؤولين الذين جرى
اعتقالهم ما يمكننا ان نعرفه في الفتره
الراهنه هو ان الرئيس المعزول الذي اطيح
بحكمه لا يزال قيد الاقامه الجبريه والامر
ايضا ينطبق على الحلقه المحيطه به وهناك
شخصيات تم توقيفها حتى
الليله تقريبا مجموعه الوزراء التي كانت
تشكل الحكومه اذا الناطق الرسمي والامين
العام
ووكيل رئاسه مجلس الوزراء اذا كلهم تم
توقيفهم في فتره بعد الظهر بالاضافه الى
ر الجمعيه الوطنيه رئيس البرلمان والوضع
يتطور حتى يوم غد طيب الان اعلن العسكريون
الذين نفذوا الانقلاب ان نجيما سيتولى
المرحله المقبله ماذا نعرف عن توجهات
الرجل السياسيه وما النهج الذي يمكن ان
ينتهجه في المرحله المقبله سواء داخليا او
حتى في علاقات الجابون الخارجيه
[موسيقى]
الان
الانقلابيون ادلوا
بتصريحات تدعو الى الطمنه
ويودون ان تعود الحياه الاقتصاديه والعجله
الاقتصاديه الى الدوران وان يعود الناس
الى اعمالهم بشكل طبيعي وسوف تبدا
الاتصالات مع الشركاء
الدوليين ان السيد
نجيما ادلى
بتصريحات مطمئنه للشركاء على المستوى
الوطني وعلى المستوى الدولي بانه ما من
احد سوف يتعرض لملاحقات غير عادله في
البلاد شكرا لك جان كلود نونام الكاتب
الصحفي من ليبرفيل
وكانت فرنسا والاتحاد الاوروبي والولايات
المتحده والاتحاد الافريقي ودول عديده قد
عبرت عن رفضها للانقلاب في الجابون ولا
يعرف حتى الان ما اذا كان هذا الانقلاب
مؤسسا على مقولات الانقلابات الاخيره في
افريقيا الدعيه الى التحرر من فرنسا ام
انه انقلاب لصالح فرنسا التي ترفض محاولات
مستعمراتها السابقه الانعتاق من سيطرتها
تقرير فوزي بشرى امي بونجو
من حيث ظن انه امن جاءه الانقلاب بقياده
الحرس الجمهوري انه الرئيس علي بونجو رئيس
جمهوريه الجابون وقد وجد نفسه خارج الخدمه
تماما كما حصل مع رئيس النيجر محمد بازوم
قبل خمسه
اسابيع يفاجئ انقلاب الجابون الدوائر
السياسيه في افريقيا وفي غربيها على وجه
التحديد وهي التي لم تفق بعد من تعقيدات
انقلاب النيجر ما تدري ماذا تصنع
معه ابلغنا المجتمع المحلي والدولي ان
السيد علي بونجو اون ديمبا يخضع للاقامه
الجبريه وهو محاط بعائلته واطبائها نور
الدين بونجو ومحمد علي ساليو وعبد الحسين
واشخاص اخرون تم اعتقالهم بتهم الخيانه
العظمى واختلاس الاموال العامه على نطاق
واسع والفسا وتهريب المخدرات وربما فاجا
انقلاب الجابون على نحو اخص فرنسا وهي
التي لم تخرج بعد كذلك من صدمه موجه
الانقلابات في مالي وبوركينا فاسو والنيجر
في غرب افريقيا المنطقه التي تشكل فضاء
المصالح والنفوذ الفرنسي المتجذر في
الحقبه
الاستعماريه ليست فرنسا وحدها قلقه بل
الاتحاد الاوروبي بدرجات متفاوته فاجتماع
وزراء دفاع الاتحاد الاوروبي المنعقد في
مدينه طليطله الاسبانيه كان قد جعل انقلاب
النيجر على اجنده نقاشاته فما انتهى الى
راي فيه حتى اخذ بانقلاب الجابون بغده
تزيد المؤتمرين حيره فوق ارتباك وبعيدا عن
مقاربه الانقلاب وفق التوصيف الكلاسيكي
لانظمه الحكم بين ديمقراطي وعسكري فان
وتيره الانقلابات في المستعمرات الفرنسيه
السابقه قد تحتاج الى نظر يخرج الظاهره من
تلك المقاربه فلكث من الشعوب الافريقيه
المحرومه من التمتع بخيرات بلادها ومنها
الجابون الدوله الغنيه بالنفط وعضو مجموعه
الدول المصدره له اوبك ستبدو الانقلابات
على نحو ما محاوله لاستكمال معنى
الاستقلال والانفكاك من الهيمنه الفرنسيه
فاكثر من ثلثي السكان البالغ عددهم نحو
مليوني و 500 الف يعيشون تحت خط الفقر كما
ترتفع معدلات البطاله الى اكثر من
20% تجربه فرنسا في مستعمراتها السابقه في
افريقيا من لدن الرئيس الفرنسي الجنرال
شارلز ديغول الى الرئيس امانويل ماكرون
تبدو غير معنيه برفاه الانسان الافريقي
عنايتها بضمان بقاء المستعمرات السابقه
تدور في فلكها لا تنفك عنه اقتصادا وسياسه
ولسانا ورغم ان الرئيس الفرنسي كان قد
المح الى ضروره مراجعه السياسه الفرنسيه
في افريقيا بقوله ان عهد فرنسا الافريقيه
قد انتهى وذلك اثناء زيارته للجابون في
مارس اذار الماضي فان فرنسا حين ذمتها
الانقلابات تباعا في مالي وبوركينا فاسو
والنيجر ثارت غاضبه ومتوعدا
الانقلابيين ومحرض على وقف انقلاب النيجر
مثلا ولو اقتضى الامر تدخلا
عسكريا لكن مما بات واضحا ان الانقلابات
تحظى بتاييد شعبي سواء لتلك التي وقعت في
غرب افريقيا داخل مجموعه اكواس او لانقلاب
الجابون وربما لان معظم الناس في هذه
البلدان لم يروا خلف القناع الديمقراطي
احدا غير فرنسا وقد يبدو من المبكر الحكم
على انقلاب الجابون ففرنسا التي تبكي على
ضياع الديمقراطيه في بعض البلدان
الافريقيه لها تاريخ ايضا في تخطيط
الانقلابات وتنفيذها مما تقول به سيرتها
في افريقيا وربما عند الصباح فقط سيعرف
الناس ان كان انقلاب الجابون لهم ام
عليهم معنا من نواكشط محمد عبد الله ولد
الطالب اعبادي الخبير في الشان الافريقي
ومدير مركز الدار للدراسات والبحوث
الامنيه والاستراتيجيه مرحبا بك سيد محمد
عبد الله اين موقع هذا الانقلاب الذي جرى
اليوم في الجابون لو نظرنا الى سياق
الانقلابات التي حدثت منذ 2020 في غرب
افريقيا مساء الخير اعتقد انه يختلف يختلف
عن الانقلابات التي وقعت في غرب افريقيا
وبخاصه الانقلاب
الاخير بالنسبه ل النظام في الغابون كما
تكلم عنه تقريركم الرئيس فقط علي بونجو
يحكم البلد منذ 14 سنه وربما تابعتم مجرات
الانتخابات الاخيره التي لم تكن يكن لها
من الانتخابات سوى الاسم يعني مكاتب تفتتح
لساعتين او ثلاثه وسائل التواصل غير
موجوده حضر تجوال الى اخره والنظام نفسه
نظام يعني متهالك الرئيس مريض منذ بضعه
سنين وامضى سنه بدون عمل و في الحقيقه
والاسره
نفسها تعريف خلافات عميقه وهي الاسره التي
تحكم البلد منذ
1962 وبالتالي فان اعتقد ان ما وقع في
الجابون عكس لما سمعت لم يكن مفاجئا لاحد
بل امر كان متوقعا
وكذلك ليست فرنسا وحدها هي ا المعنيين
بهذا الانقلاب او او المتضررين على الاقل
اكبر شريك اليوم في الغابون هو الصين
الشعبيه
لاحظت اليوم
سرعه تفاعل الخارجيه الصينيه مع الانقلاب
وضروره المحافظه على سلامته وامل الرئيس
لماذا بالضروره لماذا بالضروره كل هذه
العلاقات ستتضرر سيد محمد خصوصا وان
نيجيما ليس بعيدا عن
النظام نظام بونجو يعني هو كان حتى هو من
قلب العائله عائله
بونجو صحيح اذا كان على كل حال
التضرر قد يكون نسبيا يعني هذا شخص وصفه
الرئيس الصيني بانه صديق قديم للبلد وقد
ليس نجيما جديد وقد يكون له تطلعات اخرى
وعلي بونجو كذلك كما
تعلمون انتمى ل الكومن ويلث وبدا شيء فشيء
يبتعد عن فرنسا وعن استعمال اللغه
الفرنسيه وكذلك له مشاكل متابعات قضائيه
في فرنسا بسبب فساد هناك اذا اعتقد ان
بصفه عامه ليس هنالك من سيبكي كثيرا على
النظام الغابوني ولو ان لازالت لفرنسا
مصالح حيويه اساسيه في البلد وتوجد ما
يزيد على 12000 مواطن فرنسي في نشاطات
اقتصاديه سواء منها ما يتعلق بالطاقه وما
يتعلق بالخشب او ما يتعلق
بالمواد الغذائيه
والزراعه بصفه عامه يعني سمعنا اليوم الى
الرئيس بونجو يتحدث من مكان اقامته
الجبريه يدعو العالم للتحرك لنصرته
ومساعدته هل تعتقد ان ان هذه الدعوه لن
تلقى اي
اذان لا لاا لا اعتقد ان اليوم نظرا
للوضعيه التي يعيشها الغابون الان للاسف
كما تكلمتم عنه وضع اقتصادي جد مزري بلد
غني نظام فاسد نظام
يحكم فردي وسري حتى منذ فتره بونجو كما
تعلمون وايضا حتى بفتره عمر بونجو كانت
فرنسا فعلا حاضره بقوه وكانت حاميه وقد
افشلت عده محاولات الان الرئيس لم يعود
بتلك العلاقه الحاميه مع فرنسا حتى انه
خرج من المربع الفرنسي الضيق والصين كما
تعلمون ليست معنيه بالتداخلات في هذا
المجال وروسيا ليست ليس هنالك تواجد روسي
في الغابون والمشاكل ايضا المهمه مثل
الهجره والارهاب ليست مطروحه بشكل ملح في
الغابون وبالتالي لا ارى ان هنالك عكس ما
يقع في الساحل وفي النيجر لا ارى ان هنالك
ضروره للتدخل لهذه القوه ولكن بصفه عامه و
محاظه على الديمقراطيه وكذا يمكن ان يكون
هناك تنديد وطلب بالعوده الى النظام
الديموقراطي وخاصه ان شكرا شكرا جزيلا لك
محمد عبد الله ولد الطالب عبيدي الخبير في
الشان الافريقي ومدير مركز الدار للدراسات
والبحوث الامنيه والاستراتيجيه من
نواكشط افريقيا مخزن الثروات الاكثر غزاره
تهتز على وقع تطورات سياسيه هي الابرز منذ
عقود الجابون ضمت لحراك بدا منذ ثلاث
سنوات تقريبا في الدول التي كانت تصنف على
انها تدور في فلك التاثير الفرنسي ضباط
كبار في الجيش الجابوني يعلنون استيلائهم
على السلطه والغاء نتائج الانتخابات التي
افضت الى فوز الرئيس علي بونجو بولايه
ثالثه
قررنا باسم الشعب الجابوني الدفاع عن
السلام من خلال انهاء النظام القائم لهذا
الهدف قررنا الغاء الانتخابات العامه
ونتائجها المبتوره توصف الجابون بعملاق
النفط الافريقي تعتبر ضمن اكبر خمسه
منتجين للنفط الخام جنوبي الصحراء
الافريقيه كما تمتلك احتياطيات كبيره من
الغاز الطبيعي بمعدل انتاج يزيد على 4 54
مليون متر مكعب سنويا ابتداء من عام
2021 عدت الى مجموعه اوبيك عام
1996 بعد قطيعه عقدين من الزمن تبلغ مساحه
الجابون
270 الف كر مربع تقريبا استقلت عن فرنسا
عام
1960 حكمها منذ ذلك التاريخ ثلاثه رؤساء
فقط تعد مصدرا اساسيا للمغنيسيوم
وللنفس الى فرنسا تنضم الجابون الى النيجر
ومالي وبوركينا فاسو في انقلابات شهدها
غرب افريقيا مع فارق في التوجه السياسي
فهناك شكوك بان الحراك العسكر ليس موجها
بالضروره ضد فرنسا تدل بعض المؤشرات على
احتمال تورط باريس في انقلاب الجابون
[موسيقى]
فالمعارضة
للاشراف والامن مرحبا بك سيد بير كيف
تتابع باريس ما يحدث في الجابون ما حقيقه
الموقف الفرنسي مما
يجري فرنسا
وانسجاما مع موقفها التقليدي تدين
الانقلاب العسكري الذي جرى في الجابون لان
فرنسا تقليديا لا تعترف الا بالسلطات
المنتخبه ديمقراطيا ولذلك هي تعارض هذه
الطريقه للاستيلاء على السلطه وتنتظر
لمعرفه ما اذا كان العسكريون سوف ينقلون
السلطه الى المدنيين بالمقارنه مع الوضع
في النيجير ليس هناك دعما حقيقيا للسيد
بونجو لم تتحدث فرنسا بشكل واضح عن
الاحتيال نتائج الانتخابات ولكن هناك
افتراض بان النتائج لا لم تعكس النتائج
الحقيقيه اذا هناك انتقاد
للانقلاب ولكن في الوقت نفسه لا تعطي
فرنسا الدعم
لرئيس السابق اذا الموقف الفرنسي يختلف
بشكل مهم بالمقارنه مع الموقف الفرنسي في
النيجر لان في النيجر الرئيس انتخب
ديمقراطيا هل تعتبر سيد بير هل تعتبر
فرنسا هذا الانقلاب الذي جرى في في
الجابون ضدها وضد مصالحها وضد نفوذها في
هذا
البلد بناء على ما شاهدنا ليست هذه النقاط
التي سلط عليها الضوء العسكريون
العسكريون لديهم دعم اساسي من قبل الشعب
في الجابون
وهناك موقف ضد عائله الرئيس
بونجو الذي الذي التي هي في السلطه منذ
اكثر من 55 عاما وهناك فقر يستشري في
البلاد بالرغم من الموارد الاساسيه وقله
عدد السكان اذا هناك رفض لاسره بونجو وفي
الوقت نفسه هناك رفض للممارسات الانتخابيه
التي ترقى الى مستوى التزوير وبالتالي
موضوع فرنسا لم يكن الموضوع الاساسي
بالنسبه
الى البلاد على عكس ما حصل في النيجير
هناك مواجهه مباشره او ذكر مباشر للدور
الفرنسي في النجر الان الوضع في الجابون
يختلف ولكن يتعين عل ال سيد ب هل تعتقد
بناء على ذلك هل تعتقد ان السلطات
الفرنسيه بوارد التواصل مع العسكريين
الذين احدثوا هذا الانقلاب ومع السيد
نجيما الذي عين اليوم رئيسا ل الفتره
المقبله لا نعرف ما
مدتها الوضع لا يزال معقدا في البلاد لانه
اذا ما فتحت الحكومه الفرنسيه قنوات اتصال
معه هذا يعني ان فرنسا تقر بامكانيه
الاستحواذ على السلطه من خلال العنف وهذا
يناقض السياسات الفرنسيه ولكن في الوقت
نفسه اذا ما رفضت فرنسا اي تعاون قد تتعرض
لانتقاد من قبل العسكريين ونرى بالتالي
بلدا اضافيا ينضم الى قافله من البلدان
التي ابتعدت عن فرنسا اذا ربما هناك حل
وسط بالنسبه الى فرنسا لا تقر بالوضع
الراهن وتنتظر ان تتم الانتخابات بشكل
سريع وان تكون الانتخابات ديمقراطيه مدنيه
وبالتالي لربما يكون هذا هو الوضع الموقف
الفرنسي التي هي الان فرنسا هي الان في
موقف صعب اذا هذه هي طريقه الحوار الحوار
يتم من خلال المواقف من دون فتح قناه
مباشره شكرا لك بيير برتلو الباحث في
المعهد الاوروبي للاستشراق والامن ضيفنا
من باريس شكرا جزيلا
لك الانقلاب العسكري في الجابون يتخذ
ابعادا مختلفه ليس فقط على المستوى
السياسي والعسكري لكن اصداء الانقلاب قد
تؤثر على الاقتصاد في البلاد ايضا خصوصا
على مصالح البلدان المرتبطه بها اقتصاديا
تفاصيل اوفى في التقرير
التالي
عدوى الانقلابات في افريقيا تصل الى
الجابون والغموض الذي يلف كل شيء هناك
يبسط السؤال عن مال البلاد ليس سياسيا
وعسكريا فحسب لكن عن مالها كسوق نفط مهمه
تتجاوز حدود
المنطقه بعد لحظات من اعلان ضباط عسكريين
استيلائهم على السلطه واغلاق الحدود رست
نحو 30 سفينه تجاريه قباله سواحل الجابون
او ربما توقفت دون معرفه وجهتها التاليه
فالانقلاب هذه المره بلغ الجابون الدوله
الغنيه بالنفط والعضو في منظمه اوبيك اذ
تنتج 200 الف برميل من النفط الخام يوميا
ويشكل النفط نحو 80% من اجمالي صادرات
الجابون وهي البلاد الزخله بموارد طبيعيه
مهمه ايضا من ابرزها معدن المنجنيز الذي
يدخل في صناعات عده منها الصلب والزجاج
وبط
السيارات دوله يصل اجمالي ناتجها الخام
المحلي ل 21 مليار دولار بحسب احصائيات
العام الماضي في المقابل تضاهي ديونها
ثمانيه مليارات
دولار اما عن الشركات العامله في مجال
النفط والتعين في البلاد فتوت ال انرجيز
الفرنسيه واحده من اهمها ولديها
350 موظفا يعملون هناك وتعد شركه التعدين
ايمات الفرنسيه ايضا اكبر منتج لخام
المنجنيز في العالم بفضل منجم مواندا في
الجابون الدوله التي واكب الخبراء تعافيها
البطيئ اقتصاديا عادت لعلت في الساعات
الاولى من الانقلاب فقد انخفضت سنتها
المقومه بالدولار وبما انها مرتبطه ايضا
بالاقتصاد العالمي في شكل استثمارات
وبرامج اقتصاديه خاصه مع دول اوروبيه فذلك
لابد ان يقود الوضع الاقتصادي بها نحو
مزيد من التعقيد في ظل تلويح العقوبات من
بعيد معنا من واشنطن السفير ديفيد شن
مساعد وزير الخارجيه الامريكي السابق
لشؤون افريقيا مرحبا بك سيد السفير ديفيد
شن باي عين تراقب واشنطن هذا الانقلاب
الذي جرى في
الجابون طبعا تتابعوا الوضع باهتمام كبير
لان هذا امر اخر مقلق يحصل انقلاب عسكري
اخر في افريقيا وهذا ما يشكل معضله ليس
للولايات المتحده بل لحكومات الاخرى التي
تعترف بالرئيس المدني السابق اذا هذا باعث
قلق كبير ازاء ما حصل اليوم طيب ما الذي
يقلق امريكا في هذا
الامر من حيث
الاساس فكره استبدال
انظمه منتخبه بحكومات عسكريه
باستخدام اساليب خارج نطاق الانتخابات
ربما كان هناك مشكلات في الانتخابات نفسها
في الجابون هذا لا يس واضحا لكن الحل لا
يكمن في التدخل من قبل الجيش وازاحه رئيس
منتخب طيب الان وقد حدث ما حدث كيف
ستتعافى واشنطن مع وضعيه
الرئيس الموجود حاليا في الاقامه الجبريه
وقد ظهر وناشد العالم لكي يساعده وكيف
ايضا ستعا مع العسكريين الذين نفذوا هذا
الانقلاب في المقام الاول الولايات
المتحده وبالعمل مع جهات وبلدان اخرى سوف
تناشد الجميع بالعوده الى الحكم المدني قد
لا يثمر ذلك عن الكثير على الاقل الولايات
المتحده ربما ستحذو حظو الاتحاد الافريقي
ايا ما كانت الخطوه التي
سيتخذها الاتحاد للتعامل مع الجابون هناك
دائما احتمال فرض عقوبات لكن ليس واضحا ه
ان هذه العقوبات اذا ما فرضت ستفرض او اذا
فرضت ستنجح ما الذي يدفع واشنطن الى فرض
عقوبات في هذه المرحله يعني هل هذا خيار
جدي وواقعي يتم البحث به قبل ان يتبين ما
الذي سيفعله هؤلاء من نفذوا هذا
الانقلاب
العقوبات تنم عن مشكلات كثيره في المقام
الاول الولايات
المتحده ليس لها مشاركه اقتصاديه كبيره في
الجابون اذا العقوبات بالضروره ستكون
محدوده الاثر اذا ما تم اللجوء اليها
اما انقطع الصوت من
المصدر كما
قلت يكون موقف الاتحاد
الافريقي وايضا بلدان غربيه صديقه اخرى
والسلطات في الجابون شكرا جزيلا لك السفير
ديفيد شن مساعد وزير الخارجيه الامريكي
السابق لشؤون افريقيا ضيفنا من
واشنطن يعتزم الاتحاد الاوروبي فرض عقوبات
على قاده الانقلاب في النيجر على نفس خطى
مجموعه ايكواس حسب ما صرح مسؤول السياسه
الخارجيه في الاتحاد الاوروبي جوزيب بوريل
جاء ذلك على هامش اجتماع وزراء دفاع
الاتحاد في
اسبانيا هتفنا لرحيل القوات الفرنسيه ومن
اجل شرف الامه غير بعيد عن السفاره في
نيامي تتكرر التجمعات والمظاهرات المعاديه
للمستعمر السابق والمؤيد لانقلاب عسكري
انتقلت عدو الى الجابون يمضي قاده
الانقلاب في خطتهم غير ابهين لا بعقوبات
الايكواس ولا بالتهديد بتدخل عسكري لاعاده
الرئيس المحتجز محمد بازوم الى السلطه
يحضر الملف وبقوه في توليدو الاسبانيه
خلال اجتماع وزراء دفاع الاتحاد الاوروبي
ثمت نيه وبتحفز من برلين وباريس لفرض
التكتل عقوبات على قاده الانقلاب في
النيجر من الواضح ان الاوضاع في افريقيا
جنوب الصحراء لا تشهد تحسنا تصلنا اخبار
عن انقلاب اخر مفترض في الجابون سيقترح
امكانيه وضع اطار قانوني لفرض عقوبات على
الانقلابيين في النيجر وسيناقش
الوزراء لم يخفي الممثل الاعلى للشؤون
الخارجيه والسياسه الامنيه بالاتحاد
الاوروبي الجزئيه التي تهم اكثر وزراء
الدفاع وهي دراسه مدى ملائمه العقوبات على
قاده الانقلاب وتاثيراتها المحتمله في
التعاون العسكري والهجره يفترض ان تحسم
المساله سريعا وعلى طاويله وزراء خارجيه
الاتحاد في اجتماع الخميس توسيع قائمه
المعاقبين لحكام اليام الجدد تقابله مخاوف
تكبر لدى الامم المتحده من كارثه انسانيه
في البلد الفقير اصلا قبل يوم فقط من
دراسه الاوروبيين لاهدافهم الاستراتيجيه
من وراء العقوبات كان المفوض السامي لشؤون
الانسانيه في النيجر اعرب من جنف عن خشيته
من العواقب الانسانيه الكارثيه بسبب
الازمه السياسيه الاخيره الاخطر هو غياب
الاستثناءات حتى اللحظه في مساله العقوبات
ومع انقلاب الجابون سيزداد الوضع غموضا في
النيجر مع من ستركز الاكواس وبمن ستبدا
التدخل العسكري الذي تلوح به حسابات الامس
ليست نفسها اليوم الثابت هو غياب اجماع
اقليمي او دولي على اسلوب معالجه الازمه
ظاهره الانقلابات في افريقيا سبعه منذ
اغسطس 20 ليست امرا طبيعيا ولا عاديا كما
تصفه بعض التعليقات العنصريه ما يجري
انعكاس لازمات عميقه تجعل المواطنه
اليائسه الى ابعا حد يصفق لحكم العسكر
ويندد بالرئيس المنتخب في مشهد غريب تصنع
تفاصيله خطيا الس
والحسابات الخاصه لقوى اقليميه
ودوليه من روما ينضم الينا فرناندو نيلي
فيروتشي رئيس معهد العلاقات الدوليه
والسفير الايطالي السابق لدى الاتحاد
الاوروبي سيد
فرديناندو اذا سيد فرديناندو هل العقوبات
حل
هذه القضيه اجابتها معقده لان العقوبات
ليس لها تاثير اين ذلك مع روسيا مؤخرا
عندما قر الاتحاد الاوروبي فرض عقوبات ضد
روسيا كنتيجه لعدوان على اوكرانيا لكنها
لم تثني روسيا باي شكل ولست متاكدا من ان
ستفرض ولكن لا ادري هل ان الاتحاد
الاوروبي لديه اي بديل عن العقوبات اصلا
هذا
سيكون من
تداعيات اي قرار
بادانه الانقلابات وخاصه في النيجر وما
حصل فيها من انقلاب نحن بشكل العام نشجع
الحلول
الدبلوماسيه
ربما العقوبات هي الخطوه
المنطقيه بعد قرار ايقاف كل اشكال التعاون
ان كانت العقوبات ليست حلا ولا تستطيع ان
تغير ما يجري على الارض ما الرساله من
وراء فرضها كما يعتزم الاتحاد
الاوروبي حسب الاتحاد الاوروبي قد قرر
او نحن قررنا هو قرار سياسي ولكن ليس هناك
ايه خطوات قانونيه تم
تبنيها للمضي قدما في الخطوات التي
اتخذتها الايكواس وهي
منظمه البلدان الغرب افريقيه
المعروفه وال فكره هنا ان تطبق عقوبات
مشابهه لتلك التي فرضتها
الاكواس حتى لو ان هناك احتمال قانوني من
ان هذه العقوبات قد تغير من
موقف قاده
الانقلاب نحن نامل من ان الوضع بحد ذاته
سوف يتحول الى مرحله انتقال ديمقراطي وان
العقوبات ستقنع القاده العسكريين الان
لاطلاق راح الرئيس بازوم ولكن ماذا لو اتت
برده فعل عكسيه سيد فرديناندو ماذا لو هذه
العقوبات دفعت
بقاده القاده الانقلابيين في النيجر
بالمزيد يعني ابعد عن الاتحاد الاوروبي
ابعد عن الدول الغربيه والى معسكر روسيا
اكثر
نعم هذا خطر ماثل وموجود وبالتاكيد يجب ان
يؤخذ بعين الاعتبار بكل
حصافه حسب ما نفهم ان
العقوبات ليس الغرض منها ان تفرض على
السكان وعلى الشعب بل تجاه قاده الانقلاب
واي ارصده
ماليه كها او قدرتهم على الحركه والسفر
الى البلدان الاوروبيه اذا طبيعتها تبقى
محدوده طبعا الفكره انه بمرور الوقت سيكون
هناك ضغوط تفرض على قاده الانقلاب لكي
يعودوا
الى وضع الديمقراطي وربما حتى الانتخابات
نعم هناك مخاطره اتفق معكم بان روسيا قد
تستغل هذا الموقف وروسيا من الان موجوده
في المنطقه ربما لم تصل الى نيجر تحديدا
لكنها موجوده في عدد من البلدان المجاوره
التي شهدت انقلابات عسكريه في الماضي اذا
هناك احتمال الجاد بان هناك دورا لروسيا
وراء هذه الانقلابات شكرا لك من روما
فرديناندو نيلي فيروتشي رئيس معهد
العلاقات الدوليه والسفير الايطالي السابق
لدى الاتحاد الاوروبي
[موسيقى]
في الجابون حيث اعلن عسكريون استيلائهم
على السلطه والغاء نتائج الانتخابات
الرئاسيه وحل مؤسسات الدوله هل من
سيناريوهات افريقيه مماثله قبل انقلاب
الاربعاء في الجابون شهدت افريقيا سلسله
من الانقلابات العسكريه خلال ثلاث سنوات
نستعرض ابرز محطاتها في ال 26 من يوليو
الماضي اعلن عسكريون اطاحه الرئيس محمد
بازوم واصبح الجنرال عبد الرحمن تياني
الرئيس القوي الجديد في النيجر الى
بوركينا فاسو في ال4 من يناير من العام
الماضي اطاح الجيش الرئيس روش مارك
كريستيان كابوريه وتم تنصيب المقدم بول
هاري سانداو دا ميبا رئيسا وبعد ثمانيه
اشهر اقال الجيش د ميبه وعين الكابتن
ابراهيم تراوري رئيسا انتقاليا الى غينيا
في الخامس من سبتمبر عام 2021 تمت الاطاحه
بالرئيس الفا كوندي في انقلاب عسكري لاحقا
نصب العقيد مامادي دومبويا رئيسا وفي مالي
يوم الثام عشر من اغسطس عام 2020 اطاح
الجيش الرئيس ابراهيم ابو بكر كيتا وشكلت
حكومه انتقاليه في اكتوبر من العام ذاته
نبقى في مالي ففي الرابع من مايو
2021 اعتقل الجيش الرئيس ورئيس الوزراء
ونصب العقيد اسيمي جويتا رئيسا انتقاليا
لكن ثمه امور تجدر معرفتها عن الجابون
البلد الواقع في وسط افريقيا والغني
بالنفط حيث اعلن عسكريون انهاء النظام
القائم بحسب تعبيرهم فور اعلان نتائج
انتخابات رئاسيه كرست فوز الرئيس علي
بونجو بولايه ثالثه ثلاثه رؤساء فقط حكم
الجابون منذ استقلالها عن فرنسا عام
1960 وقاد البلد عمر بونجو لاكثر من 41
عاما حتى انتخاب ابنه علي بعد وفاته عام
2009 تسعه من ابناء عمر بونجو متهمون في
تحقيق يجريه القضاء الفرنسي منذ عام 2010
بشان مكاسب غير مشروعه وهي عقارات تم
شراؤها في فرنسا باموال عامه جابو من
الدول الافريقيه الاكثر ثراء من ناحيه
نصيب الفرد من الناتج المحلي الاجمالي
بفضل ثروه تتمثل خصوصا في النفط والخشب
والمنجنيز وعدد السكان المنخفض اتحدث عن
قرابه مليونين و300 ال نسمه الجابون من
اول منتجي النفط في افريقيا جنوب الصحراء
عام 2020 شكل النفط اكثر من
38% من ناتج الجابون المحلي الاجمالي
واكثر من 70% من مجموع صادراتها بحسب
البنك الدولي الا ان الاقتصاد الذي تعجز
السلطات عن تنويعه بشكل كاف لا يزال يعتمد
الى حد بعيد على المحروقات ويعيش واحد من
بين كل ثلاثه افراد تحت خط الفقر بحسب
ارقام اعلنت اواخر عام
2022 وفق البنك الدولي للمزيد ينضم الينا
من لندن اوساسو
اونا الكاتب الصحفي والخبير في الشؤون
الافريقيه سيد اوساسو في اي سياق يمكن فهم
ما يجري في افريقيا في الجابون وسابقا في
هذه الدول المتعدده في غرب
افريقيا الوضع ب هو كالاتي ان هناك حكومات
منتخبه والتي على
عاتقها مسؤوليه ممارسه مهامها بشكل دستوري
وباحترام لحاجات وتطلعات شعوبها تخفق في
القيام بهذه المهام والواجبات
وكنتي لذلك هناك انهيار للثقه بين الح
الحكومات المنتخبه وكثير من شعوب هذه
الحكومات مما شجع العسكر على التدخل في
السياسه وعلي ان اقول ان
وجود القوات العسكريه في الحكم هو ليس
الصواب كوسيله للحكم لاي بلد في افريقيا
الحكم الدستوري والحكم
الديمقراطي هو السبيل امثل لكن لا يمكن ان
نقول ان الديمقراطيه وحدها تكفي لان الذين
يمارسون لعبه الحكم الديمقراطي
والدستوري يجب ان يحترموا قواعد اللعبه
وعندما يخفقون في احترام هذه القواعد
والقيام والنهوض بمهامهم
وواجباتهم تجاه الشعوب التي
تنتخبهم وفقا
للدستور يخلقون بيئه تهيئ الاجواء للجيش
للتدخل وشخصيا انا اقول ان هذا التوجه
الساعد في النيجر وفي بوركينا فاسو وغينيا
والغابون هذا ليس نذيرا
حسنا لنمو الديمقراطيه والحكم الرشيد في
افريقيا طيب لو نظرنا الى الوضع من
الناحيه السياسيه سيد اساسو من المستفيد
من الخاسر مما
يجري لا اعتقد ان هذه اللعبه ما نتحدث عنه
هنا هو وضع يؤثر في حياه الملايين من
البشر في عمومي القاره الافريقيه اعتقد ان
ما ينبغي ان نتحدث عنه هو ان تكون هناك
حكومات
دستوريه
ديمقراطيه تعالج وتتعامل مع حاجات الشعوب
وتكون مسؤوله امام هذا الشعب للاسف نحن
نطيل الحديث عن الانقلابات العسكريه لكن
راينا ايضا سلسله من الانقلابات المدنيه
ماذا اقصده بالانقلابات المدنيه انا اقصد
اناس تم انتخابهم ديمقراط
لكنهم يقررون انتهاك الدساتير التي
انتخبوا بموجبها يمددون فتره بقائه طيب
كانت هذه هي المشكله سيد اساسو يعني مشكله
في الحكم المدني وفي الحكومات
المدنيه مشكله في الرؤساء المدنيين كما
راينا اليوم في الحكم الذي اطيح به في
الجابون مشكله ايضا على صعيد الانقلابات
العسكريه وتحكم العسكر زمام الامور ما
الحل ومن اين سياتي
باعتقادك الحل هو هو بسيط ويكن في ان
الذين يتم انتخابهم ليحكموا وليقضوا يجب
ان يحكموا مضامين الدستور ويجب ان يحترموا
حقيقه انهم خدم للشعب وليسوا اسيادا عليه
عندما يحكمون وفقا لمضامين ومقتضيات
الدستور ويحترمون حقيقه انهم مسؤولون امام
الشعوب التي يحكمونها في كل هذه البلدان
عند ذاك سيكون من المستحيل للجيش ان يتدخل
شكرا لك من لندن اوساسو اوباي وانا الكاتب
الصحفي والخبير في الشؤون
الافريقيه
[موسيقى]
في تطورات حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا تعرضت
العاصمه الاوكرانيه كييف لهجوم روسي
بالمسيرات والصواريخ قد يكون الاعنف منذ
شهور هجوم روسي لم تشهد له العاصمه
الاوكرانيه مثيلا منذ الربيع وفق الاداره
العسكريه لمقاطعه كي
بدا بمسيرات من اتجاهات مختلفه وتبعه هجوم
بالصواريخ ولم تسلم مناطق وسط وجنوب
البلاد من هجمات مماثله وفق قياده القوات
الجويه
الاوكرانيه ليست كيف وحدها من عاشت
التصعيد فبدور تعرضت مقاطعات عده غربيه
روسيا لهجوم واسع بمسيرات اوكرانيه كان
ابرزها في بيسكوف حيث استهدف مطار المدينه
واسفر عن تضرر اربع طائرات عسكريه ما حدث
فتحت تكهنات بشان مصدر المسيرات ف بيسكوف
تقع شمال غربي روسيا على حدود استونيا
ولاتفيا وعلى بعد نحو 800 ر من اوكرانيا
المتحدث باسم المخابرات الاوكرانيه اكد ان
الهجوم تم من خلال مجموعات محليه تعمل على
الاراضي الروسيه وفيما يمكن اعتباره
تلميحا قالت المتحدثه باسم الخارجيه
الروسيه انه لم يكن من الممكن قطع الطائرا
المسيره الاوكرانيه مثل هذه المسافه دون
معلومات من الاقمار الاصطناعيه الغربيه
الاشارات لجيران روسيا الاعضاء في النيتو
ما دفع وزيره دفاع لاتفيا لوصف الادعاءات
بعلاقه بلادها باحداث سكوف بالامر السخيف
للغايه حرب المسيرات لم تقتصر على بيسكوف
فحكم اوريول اعلن اسقاط مسيرتين اوكرانيين
فوق المقاطعه كما اكدت سلطات مقاطعات
بريانسك وكوجا ويزنس وموسكو اسقاط مسيرات
اوكرانيه
عده زخم الاستخدام الواسع للمسيرات من قبل
اوكرانيا راته دليلا على وصولها الى طريق
مسدود حسب تعبيرها اما البحر الاسود فبدور
مسرح نزال اخر حاكم مدينه سيفاستوبول
الواقعه في شبه جزيره القرم اعلن عن تصدي
الدفاعات الجويه لهجوم اوكراني بالمسيرات
وبالمقابل اعلنت الدفاع الروسيه تدمير
طائراتها اربعه قوارب سريعه في حوض البحر
الاسود على متنها نحو 50 عنصرا من القوات
الخاصه الاوكرانيه في حين اعلنت القوات
البحريه الاوكرانيه رصد ارب ع سفينه
وصفتها بالمعاد وبعضها تحمل صواريخ كروز
في البحر الاسود وبحر ازوف والبحر
المتوسط على الارض وتحديدا في زبروجيا
جنوبي البلاد يتواصل هجوم القوات
الاوكرانيه باتجاه مدينه ميليتوبول وفق
قياده الاركان الاوكرانيه وذلك بعد اعلان
استعاده السيطره على بلده روبوت في
المقاطعه لكن الدفاع الروسيه تقول انها
تصد الهجمات هناك وفي دونيتسك وتواصل عمل
ها في الجبهه الشرقيه باتجاه ليمان
وبخمس اركان الجيش الاوكراني بت لقطات
للحظه تدمير دبابه روسيه في منطقه وصفها
بالاكثر سخونه في زبروجيا بمسيره اوكرانيه
وتلك حرب اخرى في الاعلام لتاكيد التقدم
على
الجبهات استشهد فتن فلسطيني بنيران قوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي في محطه للقطار
الخفيف في حي
المصرارة وقالت وسائل اعلام اسرائيليه ان
قوات الامن اطلقت النار تجاه الفتى
للاشتباه في محاولته تنفيذ عمليه طعن وذكر
الاسعاف الاسرائيلي ان رجل امن اصيب بجروح
متوسطه جرى نقله الى المستشفى لتلقي
العلاج وافاد شهود عيان ان قوات الامن
الاسرائيليه دفعت بتعزيزات الى المنطقه
وفرضت اغلاق كاملا
عليها هذا ولقي شاب فلسطيني مصر رعه جراء
حادثه اطلاق نار وقعت داخل مخيم طول كرم
اليوم وقالت كتيبه طول كرم التابعه لسرايا
القدس ان اجهزه امن السلطه الفلسطينيه
اطلقت النار باتجاه مدنيين ومقاومين ما
ادى الى استشهاد عبد القادر زقد واصابه
اخرين اضافت كتيبه طول كرم ان مقاتليها لم
يطلقوا النار على الاجهزه الامنيه واوضحت
ان مسؤولي الكتيبه كانوا على اتصال
بالمعنيين في الاجهزه الامنيه لحل الخلاف
الا انهم فوجئوا باطلاق النار من جهته قال
المتحدث باسم الشرطه الفلسطينيه لؤي
زريقات ان الاجهزه الامنيه والشرطه باشرت
اجراءات البحث والتحري للوقوف على ظروف
وملابسات مقتله بدورها اعتبرت فصائل
المقاومه الفلسطينيه ان قتل اجهزه الامن
الفلسطينيه للشاب عبد القادر زقد في طول
كرم يمثل تجاوزا خطيرا لكل الخطوط
الحمر من جانبها دانت حركه حماس مصرع
الشاب الفلسطيني في طول كرم وقال الناطق
باسم الحركه حازم قاسم ان استشهاده برصاص
اجهزه امن السلطه جريمه وطنيه واخلاقيه
واستهتار منها بالدم الفلسطيني وشدد
المتحدث على وجوب محاسبه من اطلق الرصاص
على المواطنين في طول كرم وتقديمه للعداله
كما حث حركه فتح على اتخاذ موقف واضح من
هذه
الجريمه ودانت حركه الجهاد الاسلامي بشده
مقتل الشاب عبد القادر زقد في طول كر على
ايدي اجهزه الامن التابعه للسلطه
الفلسطينيه وحملت الحركه اجهزه السلطه
المسؤوليه الكامله عما وصفتها بالجريمه
النكراء باطلاق الرصاص على ابناء الشعب
الفلسطيني واصابه العديد منهم واكد بيان
للجهاد الاسلامي ان تمادي السلطه واجهزتها
الامنيه في ملاحقه واعتقال المقاومين
ومحاولات التضييق عليهم يمثل نهجا يخدم
الاحتلال ويعزز التنسيق
الامني
وقد وصف نائب رئيس المجلس التشريعي
الفلسطيني حسن خريشه ما يحصل في طول كرم
بال المخيف وقال في تصريح للجزيره ان
محاوله السلطه الفلسطينيه ازاله ما سماها
السواتر التي تحمي المقاومين امر لا يرضي
الفلسطينيين